this morning we continued our promise to
focus on at least one new book a week
during the pandemic today's superpower
showdown about the monumental standoff
between the US and China how it defines
our world today and how it's shaping our
future the battle between these two
nations was already a big deal before
the pandemic but a global health crisis
protests in Hong Kong and the upcoming
election have taken things to a new
level the authors of this book are two
reporters with deeply personal ties to
the story one of whom just had her life
changed forever I was forced to leave
because of the you know government order
earlier this year as the coronavirus
moved from China across the rest of the
world
Ling Ling Way found herself chronicling
another epic story then she became part
of one when you realize they were
kicking you out what was your reaction
initially was a sense of helplessness
and fear I was very frightened covering
China for the journal and always being a
job I wanted packing up and leave like
that just really heartbreaking to me way
along with other journalists from The
Wall Street Journal New York Times in
Washington Post
were tossed China said as payback for
the u.s. capping the number of Chinese
reporters allowed in America my first
thought was to quit
why didn't you I brought up the idea
with my mom and she said definitely not
you shouldn't give up
'we arrived back in the US just as the
book she wrote with her journal
colleague bob davis was about to be
released it's a book they say they've
spent their lives and careers working
toward how tough is it for you to watch
what's happened to her you know it's
very tough I was in China from 2011 to
14 I always figured if they threw me out
I go home you know I mean I'm a reporter
I'll go cover something else but for
Ling Ling it's it's exile the book is
called
superpower showdown how the battle
between Trump and
she threatens a new Cold War an
essential accounting of the tension
between the two most influential
countries of the 21st century you ask
whether we're headed to a new Cold War
some wonder whether we're already in it
I mean I think when we were writing the
book we just and finished it which is
only in the beginning of this year
things were headed toward a new Cold War
then you had Co vid on top of that and
then you had Hong Kong on top of that
and so yes it's very possible we are in
the in the midst or the beginning of a
Cold War and something that I think will
last beyond whoever wins the presidency
how long gosh I mean you know the last
Cold War lasted for 40 or 50 years I
mean we're talking about long term
changes the book takes readers back to
China's rise in the 1980s and 90s
following the devastation of the Mao
Zedong
era when China suffered terribly for
more than 30 years during in after World
War two China's returned a superpower
status in the early part of this century
was completed in cooperation with the US
until a couple things happened first the
global financial crisis of 2008 and 2009
badly soured the relationship then in
2012 she shin pang came to power there
have been so many famous or infamous
Chinese leaders over the decades
how does Xi Jinping figure into all that
Xi Jinping is the most powerful Chinese
leader at least since Deng Xiaoping and
maybe arguably since now
cheese consolidation of power and
determination to build the biggest
economy in the world
put China on an even more direct
collision course with America
then came the US election of 2016 this
is a battle that has gone on before the
Trump administration and will go on for
decades after but how has this current
administration impacted what's happened
now it intensified everything president
Trump's decision to start a trade war
using tariffs was the most extreme
economic provocation since the 1930s it
is the largest deficit of any country in
the history of our world and perhaps
eliminated any chance for dayton's soon
after President Trump won the election
he actually had many admirers in China
because because he's just so not a
traditional politician even in China
people were drawn to he's perceived
decisiveness and now now the trade war
really soured a lot of Chinese people's
attitudes the use of America I think
that's one of the fascinating things
about China it it challenges all your
beliefs about what you think you know
when it comes to politics and economics
are we learning we learned some things I
think what's happened unfortunately
lately is it is true that China has
ripped off American intellectual
property it is true that they subsidized
in an unfair fashion their companies but
if we think the reason that China is
advancing is because they're a bunch of
cheaters that's just not fair we saw in
phase one of the historic trade deal the
US and China did sign a fragile trade
truce in January but no one seems to
believe it's a long-term solution to the
bigger broader war taking place in this
war who are the winners right now I
don't think there are any winners the
way I look at it is it's like you know
three to three in the bottom of the 17th
inning and they're pulling in the
pitchers from the right fielders because
everybody's you know everybody's
exhausted what do you hope people take
away from this book you know I guess
what I hope is that they have a greater
appreciation
Asian for you know for the difficulties
of these two countries getting together
or getting along these are the two most
important countries for the 21st century
the Chinese people are just an
incredibly admirable culture and so are
the American people you know and if we
could somehow try to get back to that in
some fashion that would be a plus for
everybody Bob and Ling Ling are just
great Dana and imagine being Ling Ling
in the middle of coronavirus you're sent
out of the country then and have to go
straight to New York City Jeff just a
fascinating story that they both have on
their own but really the history and
I've been able to see some things
recently really eye-opening for so many
of us thank you for shedding some light
here